me, I would say that most
of even contemporary views
about Creoles are still
driven by the same racism that
characterized slavery.
And then they
conclude, and I want
to take that conclusion very
seriously, that although we
might use a label "Creole,"
but that label doesn't mean
that we have a linguistic
structure or class of Creole
languages.
The term "Creole" is
just a historical term
that applies to this
particular group of languages,
but isn't referred to special
developmental or special
structural patterns.
They're just a language,
that's what the Creole is.
But then, what we have to ask
is where do we go from here?
What was the issue there?
And in fact, we can do one
thing that-- and this is
from Mufwene's work.
I like this map
because what is shows
is what we discussed earlier.
The fact that if you really
look at Creoles without biases,
and you think of
the development,
and you go back in
time and you think
of the development of
Romance languages--
so this is the way
Romance evolved.
So Latin conquerors going from
Rome into Gaul, Iberia, et
cetera, that's how the
Romance languages were
created, through conquest
and contact of populations.
And the same way, if you look
at what happened to French when
French went to North America,
the Caribbean, Africa,
all the way to Asia, that's
also how Creoles were created.
You got Haitian Creole,
[INAUDIBLE] Creole, Mauritius
Creole, Seychelles Creole.
And this is where you
get the Kreyolofoni,
alongside Francophonie,
of course.
But the claim I've
made so far is
that you have similar
patterns, not only in terms
of language contact
but also in terms
of structural development.
So from that
perspective, again, there
need not be this divide,
this fundamental divide
that linguists often draw
between language change,
as in the history of French,
and then Creole formation,
as in the history
of Haitian Creole.
Earlier we talked
about these myths
about the [INAUDIBLE] of Creole.
So now what we could ask is--
in case you want to
read more about it.
So you can go to my website.
And you find lots and lots of
arguments against this idea
that you have this cycle.
Let's go up to now.
And here I'm going to be
using some of the slides
that I showed at
the UN last week.
So because what we
want to ask, connecting
to the issues of
identity and education
that were touched on
by Karen and Rachel is,
why do these myths endure?
Actually, now this, I
can go quickly, actually,
because you've seen
all of these before.
I just wanted to bring
them back there quickly.
Again, you find this
myth in very well
read, popular newspapers,
magazines, like Newsweek,
The New York Times, Reuters,
even The New Yorker.
And all of these share something
in common that we saw earlier,
that now should be too
familiar, which is Creoles
are French Patios,
broken French,
they're like
primitive languages.
Or, this one is the most poetic.
And I like this one
because it makes me
into a special
specimen of humanity.
Because really,
that what it means.
As I like to say when I give
this talk in public, when
I switch from speaking
English to speaking Creole
I go from being a modern human
to being a primitive human
because I can all of a
sudden, on my tongue,
I get to pronounce these
linguistic fossils, which
are the equivalent of
the Galapagos to Darwin.
This is spectacular.
This is a spectacular claim.
And this is Newsweek, this
is The New York Times.
It's to show you how
acceptable these claims are.
But then, again, to wrap up
from what we discussed earlier,
this is very much in sync
with Michel-Rolph Trouillot.
Now this is going back to
the early part of this class,
where we were
looking at history.
So what we see is that
the same way that Creoles
have been silenced,
the fact that Creoles
are normal languages
that has been silenced,
is often the same way that
ancient history has been
silenced for the same reason.
Because how many of
you, before this class,
knew about Haitian history?
You because you have
a Haitian boyfriend.
[LAUGHTER]
And when I ask that question,
even in big classes like 24.900
with hundreds of students, I get
maybe one or two people to know
that the Haitian revolution
was even more dramatic in terms
of its claims than both
the French and the American
revolutions.
It was the only one
in the 18th century
to proclaim liberty
and equality for all.
The only one.
The French one, the
French still had slaves.
The American one, Jefferson,
Madison, all these guys
still had slaves.
And Haiti was the
only revolution
where there was this
claim for liberty for all.
This is from Trouillot that
as Haiti was entering history,
it was being written
about by people
who did conceive of the Africans
as equals to the Europeans.
So they could only read,
according to Trouillot,
those 18th century scholars.
They could only
read the news only
with the ready-made lenses.
And it meant that
African liberation,
the fact that an African
army could win over Napoleon,
they couldn't process that.
It was incompatible with the
idea of [INAUDIBLE] revolution.
And the same way for language.
So the same scholars looking
at Haiti's revolution,
they're also looking
at Creole language.
They couldn't imagine.
For them it was
impossible that Creoles
would be no more languages.
So you can just pass on that.
So this is very familiar.
So this is the root
of all these myths.
So the root of these myths
is basically, the idea
that the Africans were lesser.
And whatever they could produce
as language had to be lesser.
Therefore they could not be
part of this same kind of theory
as normal language change,
as they [INAUDIBLE]
So again, we can say
it's the economy, stupid.
Meaning that the driving--
in fact, this is not clear.
So yesterday, Noam Chomsky
was in Black Matters,
and I asked him that question
about what came first,
the economy, empire, or racism?
Because one could say that
racism is a result of empire.
If you want to make the
Africans as slaves of labor
in order to produce
wealth, then you
are going to demean the color,
the culture, the language.
Or was racism there
before, and therefore
made it OK to make
them into slaves.
That's a hard
question to answer.
It's hard to know.
Maybe the two, as
Chomsky puts it,
the two reinforce each other.
You see that in the
case of Haiti, though,
we have all these documents
that show that clearly,
one of the driving forces
behind the Black Code, which
was a code to regulate the
slaves in the Caribbean,
the driving force
behind it was economics.
Something like that.
So it's the idea that
the Creole Blacks
are superior because they
are in the company of whites,
something like that.
"For all the tasks, it
is the Creole slaves
that are preferred."
And here, the idea is they said,
the Creole slaves are those
who are born in the Caribbean,
they have African ancestry
but they were born
in the Caribbean.
And they have more worth.
Why?
Because they are
being assimilated
into European culture.
Talking about assimilation.
So here, assimilation
comes with the benefits.
As you're being
assimilated you acquire--
and actually this guy, this
is the same guy, actually,
who came up with this
[INAUDIBLE] pulse of blood.
We could compute qualities
of different mixes
based on the quanta of blood.
White blood, this
is black blood.
He also had quanta
in terms of the worth
of Creole slaves versus those of
African slaves, a quarter more.
So imagine.
And of course, the idea
that what made them better
is because they had
been assimilated.
In this case, he used a
poetic term, "embellished."
But the mysticity,
meaning slavery by whites
would embellish
the black species.
So this is some
of the background
behind all these claims
about Creole languages.
But of course, the other part
of the background that you know
is the fact that there
was this revolution that
had to be silenced.
This is the book that
you read, actually,
part of it that you read
about silencing the past.
And so what I'm driving at
here is that all of this
together creates the
roots of these views
that Creole is so special.
And again, just
for good measure,
I want to stress
again, especially
as we wrap up this course,
that these notions of Creoles
being lesser and to
be excluded, actually,
they've been fought against,
even in the 19th century.
So this is Dessalines,
our first president.
And now this that
famous quote in French,
because it's written
by a French observer.
But the key point
here is the fact
Dessalines would get very upset
when someone was back then--
well, they weren't Haitian
yet because it was still
under the colony.
But he would tell anyone
who spoke French to him
that, why do you speak French?
You have your own language.
So this is Creole actually.
[SPEAKING CREOLE],, you
have your language.
And as he was looking
at them with disdain,
why look for another language?
Why look for someone
else's language?
So the point here
is that Dessalines,
even as he was technically
a French citizen
as he was fighting
for independence,
he understood the power
of the Creole language.
Now that's [INAUDIBLE]
This is to remind
you this line between your
politics and identity.
So this is one of the first--
1805-- law in Haiti
creating Haiti.
So this is Article 1.
"The people inhabiting the
island, formerly St. Domingo,
agree to form themselves
into free state
sovereign and independent
of any other power."
So this was the most
disturbing part about Haiti.
Slavery is abolished.
This was 1805, at a time when
both Europe and the Americas,
both North and South
America, including countries
like Colombia,
Venezuela, Bolivia,
who actually benefited
from Haiti in terms
of their own independence,
they still had slaves.
So slavery is forever abolished.
But the part that,
remember, is also important
is that excluding whites from
owning any piece of Haiti,
which has now been changed.
But that point that
I want to stress
is the fact that
Dessalines understood also
the power of identity.
Now this is 1805.
And he says that,
"all acception"
means difference of color
With [INAUDIBLE],, "The Haitians
shall henceforth be known only
by [INAUDIBLE] of blacks."
That's 1805.
NICK: What's this
written in, English?
MICHEL DEGRAFF: Well, remember,
this was at a time when--
this was both in
English and French
because Dessalines
understood that he
had to let the world know
that this is my position.
So this book here
answers this question.
Why was Dessalines, since
he was so pro Creole,
why was he writing in
French and English?
And the point is that when you
he was speaking, like here,
here was being in Creole.
But when he had people
write for him, because most
of the time he had
people write for him,
he wanted the world
to understand what was
his position about this issue.
So he had to write
in French and English
because he was speaking
not to Haitians,
but he was speaking to the USA.
This is opposition.
So be aware.
But then of course, this
is a book by Paul Farmer.
So this part is moving
from 1805 to the present.
And then to understand
why up to today
there's still this struggle
around language and entity
in the Caribbean,
especially Haiti.
From the very beginning,
after independence,
there was all this
pressure for Haiti
to remain in the
French dominion.
And then American dominion.
As you know, America, the US
occupied Haiti for 15 years
in the early part
of the 20th century.
But even in 1825,
the French managed
to extract this
indemnity from Haiti.
This was huge back then.
I think this is now worth
billions of dollars.
Can anyone read this from here?
Who wants to read this?
OK, Karen.
KAREN: "President Boyer
for 150 million francs
and the halving of customs
charges for the French trade--
all as indemnity for the losses
of the plantation owners.
These conditions
accepted in 1825,
led to decades of French
domination of Haitian finance
and had a catastrophic
effect on the new nation's
delicate economy.
Despite its nominal
independence,
Haiti could not escape from the
shackles of foreign domination.
The very fact of
the debt to France
strikes the modern
observer as odd.
Why might a country
of former slaves
feel compelled to remunerate the
plantocracy for losses incurred
in a war of liberation?"
MICHEL DEGRAFF: So the
answer is that the elite
had to make this compromise.
The elite wanted
to be recognized
by Europe and by America.
So that question here points
to this basic struggle
in Haitian history, that
from the very beginning,
the new elites that became
the leaders of the country,
they in many ways repeated
what the French had done.
This is now after
the earthquake.
This is from The Boston Globe.
And this is a
straight continuation
of what Paul Farmer discussed
in that previous quote.
So who wants to
read this part here?
STUDENT 2: I can.
STUDENT 3: Go ahead.
STUDENT 2: "The question now is
whether the wealth elite that
controls the bulk
of the economy will
help rebuild Haiti and create
a thriving middle class.
80% of Haitians live in
poverty, while a handful
of often light-skinned
descendants of the French,
who ruled the country's coffee
and sugar slave plantations
until Haiti declared
independence in 1804,
and other groups control
most of the wealth."
MICHEL DEGRAFF:
So basically, you
see the cleavage is still there.
This cleavage-- and I think
here we can refer back to Karen
and Rachel's presentation--
this cleavage between
the elite and the masses
also has this reflex,
this linguistic reflex,
where French is a language
of power versus Creole
being a language that's
still struggling to become
a tool for liberation.
So here, I think we have
this tight connection,
this tight nexus between
language, power, and identity.